PAUL IRISH: Hi.
So welcome to another episode
of the Breakpoint, where we
dive into tools to make you a
more productive developer
making web apps.
And we have a full crew today.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: So I'd also
like to introduce
[? Cyndra Sawhouse, ?]
who is a contributor on Yeoman,
very active in the
JavaScript community.
But we're going to dive into
a lot of things today.
This is the Source Map
Spectacular episode.
So we're going to talk about
source maps, source maps for
SAS, source URL, project
configuration stuff, JS Run,
Yeoman, keyboard shortcuts and
developer workflow inside of
the Chrome Developer Tools.
ADDY OSMANI: So
MALE SPEAKER: Wholesome.
ADDY OSMANI: Let's
get started!
Let's do it!
PAUL IRISH: First thing we're
going to start off, we're
going to do some source
map stuff, so let's
switch over to my screen.
Now, source maps, just to
review, provide a language
agnostic way of mapping source
to destination of code.
Now, there's a fantastic
article about it, very
exhaustive on HTML5 Rocks that
Ryan Seddon wrote, and it
talks a lot about what you can
do, but just to show an
example of how this works.
So I have a small little web
app, and as you can see, we're
just changing colors.
Pretty great.
Let me View Source on this.
So here, down where we have
the scripts, we originally
used JQuery, we had a set-up
script and then this JS, we
minified and concatenated,
like we should,
so that's all there.
But you notice down at the
very bottom of this is a
Source Mapping URL, and this
points to a JSON file.
Now, that JSON file was
generated, in this case, by
Closure Compiler, but what it
allows me to do is when I open
up my Dev Tools, hide away my
secrets, and go over to my
Sources, while the page itself
is loading in the compiled and
single minified file, since I
have Source Maps enabled here,
what I'm actually seeing
in Sources
are my original scripts.
And the other benefit here, in
addition to just seeing these
things, is that things like
Breakpoint still work.
So when I set a breakpoint
inside this file, I can click.
And so the browser is actually
interpreting the minified
file, and you can see that
because over here in my Scope
Variables, I'm looking at a
variable called P, but really,
that's actually the text
variable here.
So the browser's doing the
minified, I'm getting the
original one, so I can
do breakpoints and
do breakpoint debugging.
MALE SPEAKER: So there's kind
of no point in waiting until
the end of your project to get
all your JavaScript smushed
down to this kind of
concatenated, minified form.
You may as well do it earlier
on, and then kind of roll with
source maps?
What do we recommend?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, that's
a good question.
So I think during development,
you're still probably going to
want to develop with the
original source.
There's downsides, right?
I cannot actually just
see what's in the
text very well here.
Maybe this will come later,
but for now, that's this.
I think this is a big boon for
debugging a production
environment.
But there's other things in
addition to just the fact of
going from minified source back
to the original sources,
so let's dive into that now.
When Source Maps came out,
everyone was really excited
about, what about Coffeescripts,
right?
That's what they're asking.
So Coffeescript redux is an
alternative Coffeescript
Compiler that Matthew
[? Fakara ?]
has been working on for
a long time now,
and it's very active.
And this new Coffeescript redux
compiler can create
source maps.
There's another project, too,
that has just reached a new,
exciting state, which
is Uglify JS 2.
A new version, it is now
finished and stable, and it
also generates source maps.
And not only that, but it can
consume source maps, too.
So if you see here, it will
consume a source map, and then
you can generate a new one.
MALE SPEAKER: I was
really confused.
You mentioned this earlier, and
I was like, this is the
source map, and you can--
ADDY OSMANI: Source
map [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: But why
would Uglify?
Uglify should create
a source map.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It should.
MALE SPEAKER: So why does
it take a source map?
PAUL IRISH: Because you want
to take something like a
Coffeescript--
you can also take type script,
which creates a source map--
consume its source map, and then
go down to minified code,
because that's what we want
out of Uglify, right?
But we want to take our minified
app, and then when
we're debugging it, go back
to the original, original
sources, which in this case,
is not even JavaScript.
MALE SPEAKER: OK so we take the
one that Uglify gives us
to get back to the Coffeescript
compiled
JavaScript, and then we take the
Coffeescript source map to
go back into the Coffeescript?
PAUL IRISH: Pretty
close, yeah.
The browser only ends up dealing
with one single map,
so the map is mapped.
So this is all explained in a
great post, again by Ryan
Seddon, called Multilevel Source
Maps where he talks
about how this works and
shows a nice demo.
And I'm going to quickly
show my own demo.
So let's see.
I'm here in this little thing.
I'm just going to log out this
small little piece of
Coffeescript.
We're just iterating over in
Array, we're mapping, and then
we have this long form text
string, and we dropped the
results of both of these things,
this math stuff and
the Shakespeare, into Argon.
Now, I compiled this with the
Coffeescript Redux compiler,
and it turned into this.
So generated by Coffeescript,
here's my JavaScript, and
that's all looking good, and
you'll notice down at the
bottom, this is how I refer
to that source map URL.
Then, I went to Uglify, and I
said, hey man, hook it up.
MALE SPEAKER: Just like,
smush this down.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
It looks something like
this right here.
So we consume that map, we
generate a new one, and we
output to this new min JS.
So let me bring up what this
looks like in the browser.
So if I just View Source, I have
a test.min.js, but in my
Sources Panel, I have my
original Coffeescript with
working breakpoints.
Very nice.
MALE SPEAKER: Really slick.
PAUL IRISH: Very nice.
So there it is.
MALE SPEAKER: So two steps.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
A combo.
So Source Maps has gotten
a very active community.
A lot of tools create them.
This is essentially, the living
document that tracks
all the activity in
Source Maps now.
Over on GetHub, look up Ryan
Seddon in GetHub Source Maps,
you'll find it.
The current languages
that generate Source
Maps, such as [? JWBT ?]
projects, the Tracer project.
This Mozilla Source Map
JavaScript project does this
source map creation, and both
of these projects that I've
shown use this.
There's a lot of other good
stuff worth clicking around.
Spend some time exploring
this.
Now, I want to switch over to
non-JavaScript source maps.
In the last episode, we talked
about dev tools in SAS, right,
and I opened up HTML5
Please, we looked at
kind of this [? H1 ?]
and look, we're actually
referencing the [? SESS. ?]
I click over here, and so
we add line mapping.
And the current implementation
is just that.
It just is line mapping, and
using these little hints about
location to go over there.
That's cool.
In fact, that's really cool,
so cool that Felix
[? Ganoss ?]
he added pull requests to both
Less JS and Stylus to add the
same line number mapping to
those so that you can get the
same benefits.
ADDY OSMANI: So for all those
people that had been wondering
whether Less and all the other
solutions were going to get
this support--
PAUL IRISH: Boom.
ADDY OSMANI: Tada.
PAUL IRISH: So those just went
up yesterday, so they're not
in the projects yet, but
they're pretty awesome.
But in the meantime, this is
just using this kind of hack
to get line number mapping.
It's not using real source maps,
because no tool has had
the ability.
But this over here on the SAS
repo is an active pull request
contributed by the Chrome Dev
Tools Team to add actual V3
source map generation into
the SAS compiler.
MALE SPEAKER: That's so cool.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
So as far as what this will do,
let's say a few things.
We know, basically, in the
compiled CSS, where everything
that's in there came from.
So let's say you have a color
called Red, and it originally
came from a variable.
You can Command-click from the
Elements Panel that red, and
it'll jump back to its original
location, where you
can make that change.
Let's say the value was
evaluated because of some math
in a function.
You would Command-click, and it
would go directly to that
evaluation point.
And if a property's
source was from a
mix-in, it would go there.
So we can go directly from what
we're looking at in the
CSS back to where it came from,
even considering a bunch
of transformations and actual
logic happens [INAUDIBLE].
So that's really cool.
So I can't wait to really demo
how this really works.
That's something to
look forward to.
One last quick on.
Can I do that?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, sure.
MALE SPEAKER: Go for it.
You're doing great,
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Source URL.
Source URL is a little
funny one.
So this is a little
tricky to explain.
I'm going to bring
up some code.
Actually, you know what?
Here, we'll just bring
up my console.
Eval, let's see, console.log
document window.
Does that work?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: [INAUDIBLE].
Now, typically when you eval, it
just evaluates, but there's
no way to retain that
and access it later.
Now, Source URL actually
gives us this ability.
Now, you might be looking at
this and being like, why would
you ever want to hold on to an
evaluation that you're just
doing right here?
[? hi-hi.js. ?]
So if you see, this just
added [? hi-hi.js ?]
in my Sources Panel.
This is here.
This is pretty cool, that I
can treat this like a real
script, I can add breakpoints,
and with a much more
significant evaluation.
So typically, this will happen
inside of Framework.
The Framework will be doing some
transformations, let's
say it's a templating Framework,
that's creating
compiled templates, and it can
just add them into here on the
fly, generating the file name.
The other thing that just got
added with Source URL is the
ability to do the same thing,
not just for evaluated text,
but for inline script tags.
So if I take a little bit
of code from over here.
So this right here, I'm just
creating a script element,
tossing something into it, and
then adding it to the DOM.
Now typically, this will just
throw it away, but again, I
can add my Source URL into here,
and now, it actually
lives, hypothetically.
Demo fail?
Ah.
There's a very important space
that's required right here.
MALE SPEAKER: There we go.
Awesome!
PAUL IRISH: So the way that I'm
showing this is a little
weird because why would you ever
want something from the
console to go over here, but
this is really important in
larger frameworks that manage
script evaluation for you, or
anything like that.
MALE SPEAKER: Are we gong to
see Frameworks actually
starting to support this?
PAUL IRISH: Ember uses this
really well, so they have a
way to collect all the modules
and evaluate them.
So the modules are collected and
actually executed as only
a single JavaScript file, but
you authored them in a lot of
different files, and it's
actually just running them all
through a bell, but using Source
URL so that you have a
very enjoyable debugging
experience.
So yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: That's
really cool.
PAUL IRISH: It's good stuff.
ADDY OSMANI: I like it.
MALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Well done.
That was like--
PAUL IRISH: All right, you want
to show us some stuff?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: So what are you
going to talk about?
SINDRE SORHUS: So I'm going
to talk about some project
configuration files you should
use in a project.
So I have some templates I
usually use when I start a new
project to make it easier for
people to contribute to my
code, while still keeping my
preference on different code
style preferences.
So the first one is dot get
attributes [INAUDIBLE].
You should [? press always ?]
on a route folder, and
it applies to all
your files in a project.
So what it does, this one, it
just all the text files--
yeah, thanks.
All the text files, it will
normalize your line handlings
to Unix, because some people
might be on Windows using
Notepad [INAUDIBLE], and you
don't really want to mix
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: So this makes a
difference because Windows has
character return line
feed, and Linux is
just line feed, right?
SINDRE SORHUS: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: And if you check
out a repo and it's different,
Get will start to say,
I'm going to
change some stuff here.
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah.
It's really messy, so
you don't want that.
MALE SPEAKER: This makes
this go away, right?
SINDRE SORHUS: Exactly.
MALE SPEAKER: I like that.
SINDRE SORHUS: You just put it
in a repo, and magically, you
don't have to think about it.
PAUL IRISH: That's awesome.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, I like
not thinking about it.
SINDRE SORHUS: We also have
[INAUDIBLE], which if you
don't know what Travis is--
PAUL IRISH: Want to bring
that down [INAUDIBLE]?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah, I'll bring
it down, of course.
So Travis is a continuous
integration system which
actually tests your code when
you push, and on the commits,
and stuff like that.
PAUL IRISH: There are quite a
few Open Source projects using
[INAUDIBLE], aren't there?
Actually, Modernizer's
using it.
SINDRE SORHUS: Modernizer,
Yeoman, of course, JQuery.
So it's very popular.
It's free for Open Source.
Yes sir?
PAUL IRISH: [INAUDIBLE]
switch over to my screen.
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: So we'll just
show this real quick.
This is Travis in use
on Modernizer.
Incoming pull requests, Travis
pulls them, and then evaluates
them, and basically runs the
Modernizer Test Suite on their
servers against the actual
pull request.
So this runs using Node, it
checks out dependencies and
evaluates my queue unit test
suite, and lets me know that
everything's fine, test suite
passes, we're good.
SINDRE SORHUS: And that makes it
a lot easier to manage big
projects with lots of
[INAUDIBLE] requests and stuff
like that, because--
ADDY OSMANI: I mean, the first
thing that you do whenever
someone sends you through a pull
request is check to see
if it passes your test, so it
just saves you so much time.
SINDRE SORHUS: Exactly.
It saves you so much time, and
then you can be confident this
actually works, because
it passes the tests.
And another file I usually put
in, it's not real well known,
but it's very useful.
It's called Editor Config.
What it does is try to define
some rules that you usually
want in your editor.
Like I prefer tab indentation,
so I just mention there.
And I prefer Unix [INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: We're going
to get so many
comments about this.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ADDY OSMANI: Fight,
fight, fight.
PAUL IRISH: We brought this up
last night, and we actually
did have a [INAUDIBLE]
versus spaces.
MALE SPEAKER: You did not.
PAUL IRISH: We did.
ADDY OSMANI: Nobody comes out
good from that fight.
SINDRE SORHUS: In fact,
[INAUDIBLE] never-ending
battle because you're never
going to agree.
PAUL IRISH: There were
some good arguments.
MALE SPEAKER: It's almost like
people are fighting over a
preference, though.
It's strange.
ADDY OSMANI: It's a very
personal thing.
MALE SPEAKER: It is.
PAUL IRISH: So here, you're
able to define your
preferences for the
entire project.
SINDRE SORHUS: For the entire
project, and team or
collaborators on the project.
MALE SPEAKER: That's good,
because it removes headaches,
doesn't it, when everybody's
sharing the same thing.
At least you know what
you're getting into.
I like that.
SINDRE SORHUS: You also have
the most well known, it's
called JS Hints, which
[INAUDIBLE], and it defines
some code consistency rules, and
in general makes your code
better by forcing it to
adhere to some rules.
Like for example, I put
up some of the--
they're [? pretty neat, ?] not
very well known, but they're
really useful for code
consistency and making your
code actually better.
Like I prefer single quotes,
because that's the best.
Right?
ADDY OSMANI: It's a choice.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah, whatever.
And you can define
trailing, which
actually informs you if--
PAUL IRISH: Do you have
a demo of this, or an
example of how it works?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes, exactly.
So here, we have just user
code, JavaScript code.
So Sublime highlights for me
when I have trailing spaces,
but most don't.
PAUL IRISH: So Sublime is using
your [INAUDIBLE] rules?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes.
Not at the moment, because that
would be too much stuff,
but I'm going to explain
it anyway.
So if [? earlier, ?]
this is my code and save,
[INAUDIBLE] is going to shout
at me, of course, because
that's a rule and I
should follow it.
And there are some other useful
stuff, like you can
define a max length, which will
inform if you don't wrap
your lines at--
I think I defined 80.
Yeah, 80.
And if most--
a lot of JavaScript don't know
JS development, and the thing
about that is the [INAUDIBLE]
measure actually makes
it really hard not
to get into a callback--
MALE SPEAKER: Callback hell,
I think is the [INAUDIBLE].
SINDRE SORHUS: Callback
hell, [INAUDIBLE].
So what this does, it actually
informs you if you try to nest
your code more than the set
level, like I prefer two or
three because of the
[INAUDIBLE], you should just
put your function outside
the nested callbacks.
So that's really good to
actually try to simplify your
code and make it easier for
others to contribute.
MALE SPEAKER: I like
the max params one.
We were talking about
this earlier.
This is this idea that I guess
if you get too many
parameters, it just becomes this
kind of, which one am I
setting, especially if you call
that function, because it
would be like, true, false,
false, true, five, and it
becomes very hard for
somebody to--
which one was that again,
which parameter?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah, that's
called the Boolean trap.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
So this is the idea that if you
get over three, in this
case, it's going to suggest that
maybe you might want to
bounce that down to an object,
or something else that can
[INAUDIBLE].
SINDRE SORHUS: [INAUDIBLE],
because then you don't have to
care about--
ADDY OSMANI: And this is a
pattern people have seen with
at least JQuery, if nothing
else, using objects instead of
having insane numbers
of parameters.
PAUL IRISH: I like that in JSN,
we now have rules to keep
you from shooting yourself in
the foot as you're developing,
but also things like this, which
is code to ensure good,
healthy code over the lifetime
of a project so others
developers are not coming in
and making poor mistakes.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, it's really
good, like you said,
because that maintenance thing,
it can be really hard,
especially with a lot of people,
and sometimes you just
want to ship.
And this kind of keeps you on
the straight and narrow a
little bit, and just
forces you to--
I don't know, maybe sometimes
I've started a project well,
and then over time,
it may have got a
little worse, possibly.
SINDRE SORHUS: Possibly.
MALE SPEAKER: This might
be useful for me.
SINDRE SORHUS: Exactly.
So you should use all those
files in projects.
It's easy.
Just have them in a
folder, copy them
over on a new project.
PAUL IRISH: So my Get
Attributes, Travis, Editor,
Config, [? JSN. ?]
SINDRE SORHUS: Exactly.
And they all have websites,
so just Google it.
MALE SPEAKER: I like it.
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah.
And, you want to introduce?
PAUL IRISH: Yes.
So you're going to show us an
extension that you wrote for
Sublime, and this actually came
because my friend uses--
I think MatLab has
this ability.
You're looking at code, you
can be authoring it, and
you're just like, I want to
evaluate just these two lines
of the file, just send
that and evaluate it.
And I was like, I really want to
have this in Sublime text.
ADDY OSMANI: And you want it to
be able to run the code in
the browser, not just
inside Sublime.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, and
not in Node either.
I wanted to test it
against the DOM.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
PAUL IRISH: So you did that?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah, I thought
it looked useful, so--
ADDY OSMANI: So Sindre is one
of these people that will
respond to a comment with
a complete solution.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
quite astounding.
PAUL IRISH: Good.
All right, so you
want to show us.
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes, of course.
Here, I'm using [INAUDIBLE] new
features in Canary that
lets you style your console,
log out of it.
ADDY OSMANI: We actually showed
this in the last episode.
SINDRE SORHUS: One new feature
is now you're allowed style
multiple times.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, different
styles within the same blog.
SINDRE SORHUS: You just use
Percent C before the
[INAUDIBLE] thing you
want to style.
So here, I've defined base
style, and I just
differentiated it between
the different verbs.
I'm just going to mark
[INAUDIBLE], because that's
how we did it in [INAUDIBLE]
and run it.
PAUL IRISH: Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Nice, slick.
I like it.
PAUL IRISH: So you could be
selecting just a single line.
SINDRE SORHUS: I
could add to--
I could just--
and it runs, either a selected
line or the selected text.
So it's written nicely to
quickly test [INAUDIBLE]
stuff.
And you can do it to existing
projects too, and just modify
our method, and just override
the current page.
It's really easy.
So yeah, I think that could
be useful to some.
MALE SPEAKER: Where do
people get that?
Can they get that through--
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes,
it's currently
on GetHub, of course.
MALE SPEAKER: Look up JSRun?
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah,
it's called JSRun.
Just Google it.
ADDY OSMANI: And taking a look
at the Moderator here, I see
some people have been asking
about where they can get all
the code for what we're using.
We'll try to stick as much of
this up online after the show
as possible, so you guys
can [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: So since we saw
some stuff in the console,
you're going to show
some more.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, I'm going to
show you some more stuff.
So over--
MALE SPEAKER: Some rainbow
action in the console.
ADDY OSMANI: As you can see, I
absolutely hate this new style
console stuff.
I hate it.
MALE SPEAKER: See, it can
be used for great
good or great evil.
ADDY OSMANI: In my
case, it's yes.
This is like visual vomit.
All right.
So over the past couple of
episodes, we've been spending
a lot of time in the Sources
Panel and we've been showing
you snippets and how all
those things work.
And in some ways, this is like
working in a text editor
within the Dev Tools.
Now, when you working in a text
editor, there are some
functions that you're
commonly doing.
You're always trying to locate
files, you're trying to find
particular methods or selectors
in files you're
working on.
Maybe you want to do a text
search on a file or locate
something across your
entire project.
Now, how do you do those things
inside the Dev Tools?
So I've just navigated to the
Sources panel, and there are a
bunch of different shortcuts
that you can use to access the
features I'm going
to talk about.
Now, if you're on OSX, you could
just use Command for
some of these.
If you're on Windows,
you can use Control.
What do people do if
they're on Linux?
PAUL IRISH: Control.
ADDY OSMANI: Control.
It's Control on Linux as well.
So the first thing I'm
going to show you is
how to locate a file.
So Command O will bring up this
dialog that has basically
a list of all the different
files in your project.
And if I wanted to go to a
particular one, I can filter
down quite easily just
by typing in.
So in this case, I want
to go to script.js.
Now let's say, so I'm in a
JavaScript file at the moment,
and I want to locate a function
inside my script.
So if I go and I use Command
Shift-O this time, it'll
actually give me a list of all
the different methods in my
file, and I can go
and access them.
So if I wanted to access, say,
this function called Update
Search, I get it right away,
which is quite nice.
Let's say I wanted to do
something else, like doing a
text search on this file.
So maybe I'm not necessarily
looking for a particular
method, but for something
else.
So Control Command-F will give
you that, and you get another
little dialog in the corner, and
let's say I want to type
in Notification.
So as you can see, it highlights
the term in my
file, and I can continue using
Command-G. In this case, I can
continue just flipping through
all the different instances of
notification in my file.
PAUL IRISH: And I guess we
should point out that this
Command F to search, it searches
the current pane, and
it will work in any pane.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah so if we
went to Resources, for
example, and we did Command-F,
and I typed in something like
web, or I typed in Script, you
can see there's actually a
little notice that comes up
saying how many different
results have been found
in those files.
So in script, it'll say there's
been one thing found,
and let's see if web comes
up with anything.
So I've typed in "web," and
I'm now going through
different items in the Resources
panel that have the
word "web" in there.
This also works in Networks.
If I refresh the page, and I was
looking for something, so
inside the panel, Command-F, and
I type in something like
"normal," it'll actually go and
similarly, locate all the
items in the Network panel
that have these things.
PAUL IRISH: And then sometimes
we have this little filter
check box, too.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
That's nice, right?
That's pretty sweet.
I'm going to go back to the
Sources panel very quickly.
MALE SPEAKER: Did the filter
thing just give
you only the ones--
ADDY OSMANI: It displays only
the list of items that have
been filtered down with the
highlighting and everything.
PAUL IRISH: It's nice on
Timeline when you just want to
see the Garbage Collect
events.
MALE SPEAKER: Which I do,
actually, most times.
PAUL IRISH: And then
you just see.
Boom, boom, boom.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh,
that's the best.
ADDY OSMANI: So we've gone
through text search, we've
gone through filtering down
methods, locating files.
Now, what if you wanted to
do a text search across
everything in your project?
Now, if you do the Command
Option and then F again,
another panel will show up.
And let me just bring down the
size of this a little bit.
So you have the ability to
search sources in your
project, ignore case or type
in "Regular Expressions" to
find things based on regular
expressions.
So in my case, I want to
find a file called--
I think it's called Sing or Song
or something like that.
So I can't find the file here,
but I can find files that have
the word "sing" in them.
Let's say I want to navigate
to that file.
So Command-O, that
gets song.js.
So I've now gone and it's
actually located me a snippet
with the file name song.js.
So this works across not just
regular project files, but all
of the snippets that you
have saved as well.
Now, I'm going to show you
another quick thing.
Let me just close up that.
Let's go to our song.
So I've selected some code
in my song.js snippet.
Now if I run Command
Shift and E--
MALE SPEAKER: I think it's
Control Shift-E.
ADDY OSMANI: Sorry, it's Control
Shift-E, you're right.
You're right.
It's now gone, and it's
evaluated the selection that I
had in the console.
PAUL IRISH: Which Is basically
what we had in JS Run, but now
we just have [INAUDIBLE].
ADDY OSMANI: And it's
pretty slick.
I mean, there are so many
shortcuts in the Dev Tools
that you can use.
Another one that we wanted to
point out is actually Command
plus square brackets.
So you can actually use this to
tab back and forth between
different panels.
So let me show you
how that works.
So I'm in Sources at the moment,
and I want to go back
so I can flip through Elements,
Resources, Network
Sources, and it just works
across everything.
It's quite nice as well.
PAUL IRISH: [INAUDIBLE]?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Are we going to
get a listing of all the--
MALE SPEAKER: I was just going
to the very same question,
Paul Irish.
Wow.
PAUL IRISH: Do you
know the answer?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
It's in Dev Tools.
PAUL IRISH: Well, so there's
actually two, so there's a
little bit of an overlap.
So if you're in Dev Tools on any
pane but Console and just
hit question mark, you get a
quick listing of all the
keyboard shortcuts.
ADDY OSMANI: So question mark.
There we go.
PAUL IRISH: And so it's
all by panel.
There's also a Keyboard
Shortcuts page on the
[INAUDIBLE]
Dev Tools documentation site
that I think has a few more
beyond just these.
ADDY OSMANI: Yes.
Yes, it does.
MALE SPEAKER: Hidden gems.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
hidden gems.
And we're updating that page at
the moment to cover all of
these shortcuts.
So even if some of these things
seem like a bit of a
mystery and this is your first
time finding out about them,
we're going to try demystifying
that just a
little bit.
MALE SPEAKER: Awesome
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: Do we
have questions?
ADDY OSMANI: We've got
some questions.
Let's check out the Moderator
Queue and see what
questions we've got.
PAUL IRISH: Sergey from,
um-- oh, wow.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah?
OK.
Well, let's answer Sergey's
question, and then we'll talk
about [INAUDIBLE].
We missed our Yeoman
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Dude, we
should swing that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SINDRE SORHUS: Dude, it's like
a major [INAUDIBLE].
We should totally
talk about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's answer the
question, then [INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Sergey, we're going
to answer your question.
Sergey in Tel Aviv asks, do you
recommend to build assets
and commit them in version
control before deployment, or
to add a build hook on
a production server?
Build hook.
Well, you know-- basically,
yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: Depends.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Like most
questions, right?
PAUL IRISH: I would say, there's
no reason to ever
commit minified to
source control.
However, I could see the case
for committing optimized
images if you don't
feel like--
optimizing an image is actually
a very expensive
operation, and so it would make
sense to actually keep
those optimized inside
source control.
MALE SPEAKER: And you're not
going to want to do that every
time you do a build, right?
ADDY OSMANI: No,
of course not.
I mean, what we sometimes do
is if you have multiple
repositories and one repository
requires a minified
asset for something else, just
sub-module in that asset only,
and just use that in the
secondary project.
Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: The solution here,
I think, is to have a
[INAUDIBLE] script that you can
execute both on your local
development machine and on the
production environment.
MALE SPEAKER: But personally
speaking, I would never commit
those minified, concatenated,
particularly scripts into
source control.
PAUL IRISH: I actually don't
think that minified scripts
should be in GetHub.
I don't think they should
ever be there.
I don't think that, even
on a project page--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SINDRE SORHUS: But sometimes,
has to do it.
PAUL IRISH: Why?
SINDRE SORHUS: [INAUDIBLE], you
have to compile the page
before pushing it to GetHub.
So there are some
cases for it.
PAUL IRISH: Oh yeah, you
don't have that option.
MALE SPEAKER: But in general,
though, like if--
PAUL IRISH: You just install Mod
Page Speed in that case.
I would install Mod Page Speed
and then call it a day,
because that's going to
take care of all those
optimizations for me.
ADDY OSMANI: Now, if you haven't
heard about Mod Page
Speed before, there's actually
a good GDL episode about it.
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, watch that.
MALE SPEAKER: Very good.
ADDY OSMANI: You should
check it out.
MALE SPEAKER: But I guess the
general point that you were
making was if a developer is
going to include, say, your
library or something in a bunch
of scripts that they've
already got, they've already
got a concatenation,
minification process in place,
and you want to drop into
that, rather than giving them
your smushed down version, if
they're going to go through
that process anyway.
Is that fair?
ADDY OSMANI: So we've got a
bunch of other questions, but
before we do this--
PAUL IRISH: We're going to talk
about a project that can
actually do things like build
scripts really well.
ADDY OSMANI: What's it called?
SINDRE SORHUS: It's
called Yeoman.
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL IRISH: Yeah, your laptop
got pretty decorated
[INAUDIBLE].
SINDRE SORHUS: Yeah, I finally
got some nice stickers.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, and
you went to town.
You really did.
ADDY OSMANI: He's getting as bad
as me with the stickers.
MALE SPEAKER: All the stickers,
and a little ship in
between the Yeoman.
ADDY OSMANI: So as we mentioned
before, Sindre is on
the Yeoman team, and he's been
working a lot lately on the
next version of Yeoman 1.0.
So tell us a little bit about
what you've been doing lately.
SINDRE SORHUS: So we had to
struggle a little bit with
[INAUDIBLE]
from users for different stuff
like back end integration,
more customized [INAUDIBLE],
and a lot of stuff that we
really want to solve, but is
not really easy with the
current architecture.
We're also tied into the
current version of
[INAUDIBLE], which--
So we tried to rethink how we
were doing stuff, and we came
to the conclusion that the
easiest thing is to move a lot
of the logic that is currently
behind closed doors, far
behind [INAUDIBLE] code base,
and put them into the
[INAUDIBLE] file itself.
What this solves is that
everything is transparent to
the user because they
can see what
happens behind the scenes.
They can change it if they
want to, they can add
[INAUDIBLE] tasks.
Currently, there are like
200 plus tasks they
can make use of.
ADDY OSMANI: Is there a
place where people can
go and check out--
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes.
You can go to [? GruntJS.com ?]
which lists everything.
And that's one more thing
we want to solve
with the new release.
ADDY OSMANI: So I know that
from the first version of
Yeoman, there were a lot of
people that took a look at it,
they liked what they saw, but
then they started doing a lot
more custom stuff with their
builds, and they wanted to be
able to, in some ways, move a
little bit more towards Grunt
and a little bit more away from
some of the opinions we
had, which is totally cool.
How are we going to be solving
that moving forward, and
making it easier?
SINDRE SORHUS: As I said
with this [INAUDIBLE]
as we're calling, which just
means that we are generating
the [? Grunt ?]
file once and putting the
dependents in, in
package.json, which means
it says Grunt 0.4 there.
And you can upgrade it
whenever you want.
So you're not tied to a
specific Grunt file
[INAUDIBLE]
for you, and you can keep your
projects and dependents and
stuff if you want that.
And what that means is that it's
extremely easy to make
changes and to do whatever you
want, like if you want the
back end integration, you
can do it yourself.
We are mainly [INAUDIBLE]
front end apps at the moment.
We might explore something else
in the future, but at the
moment, with this new release,
you can do it
yourself, so why not?
PAUL IRISH: That's
really cool.
MALE SPEAKER: More control.
SINDRE SORHUS: More
control, exactly.
And that's what the users have
been asking for, so--
MALE SPEAKER: So they get it.
Give the people what
they want.
It's a good idea.
ADDY OSMANI: When can people
expect to see the
next version of Yeoman?
SINDRE SORHUS: OK, so we are
doing a pre-release that this
is going to be feature complete
in the middle of
December, and we are shooting
for a final release in the
middle of January.
So that is going to be great.
We also have some cool stuff
in the road map that we are
targeting for February, like we
want to integrate with the
editors like Sublime, and have
brackets to make it easier.
ADDY OSMANI: So people aren't
going to have to keep
switching back and forth
between lots
of different tools.
SINDRE SORHUS: Yes, exactly.
We currently have a built system
for Sublime, which is
really naive.
You can trigger Build and Save
and stuff like that, but we
want to get a little more
integration with different
editors, so that's going
to be really nice.
It is also going to make it
easier for people that aren't
really that comfortable
with command lines.
And we are also thinking about,
currently, it's very
hard to debug a mobile.
When you're creating mobile
apps, a lot of people
[INAUDIBLE], really.
We want to make it easier to
debug a mobile by integrating
with some debugging solutions
like Android, so we are going
to explore that, too,
in the future.
Yes, and also, we are currently
[INAUDIBLE]
generator [INAUDIBLE]
Yeoman in it.
We've heard some dependencies
that we need, like HTML5
boilerplate, and other stuff,
that's currently [INAUDIBLE]
from Get directly.
What we are going to change
in the future is to start
fetching everything from
[INAUDIBLE], which is the
package manager we
currently use.
And what that means, it's going
to be super easy to keep
those dependencies up to date
because they're already in the
registry, and you can just
run your month update.
So this is going to
be really nice.
MALE SPEAKER: A lot of exciting
changes around the corner.
ADDY OSMANI: Lots of fun stuff
to look forward to.
SINDRE SORHUS: Paul published
a road map.
You can go to the Yeoman
wiki and look at it.
And we allow some comments and
feedback about the possible
future, how do you
think about that.
PAUL IRISH: I think it's good.
A lot of the static Grunt file
stuff that Sindre mentioned,
you're able to much more
declaratively specify your
configuration and how you want
these operations to have,
instead of it being kind
of in Yeoman somewhere.
And then it also allows for
better flexibility and
extensibility when you say that,
I know, Yeoman, you do
it this way, but I've got to
make this change and swap out
one thing for [INAUDIBLE].
SINDRE SORHUS: [INAUDIBLE]
a common one.
And it's also going to make
it easier for us to create
customized builds, like you
don't really want to build the
same if you're creating a Chrome
extension, instead of
[INAUDIBLE], or a [INAUDIBLE]
plug-in.
So this is going to be
more customized.
PAUL IRISH: So we're excited.
We have some ideas on this.
But really, we want to help
everyone build web
applications in a more
productive way.
And so if you have any ideas on
how we can help with that,
please feel free to
leave a comment.
OK, is this it?
ADDY OSMANI: Do you want
to answer any more
questions, or are you--
PAUL IRISH: One more question?
ADDY OSMANI: One
more question.
Let's do one more.
Do you like any of those?
Can we answer any of them?
PAUL IRISH: Yeah.
You want to pick one?
OK.
So Sergey asks--
MALE SPEAKER: Sergey again?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL IRISH: He gets two
questions answered, yeah.
So Sergey asks about
redeveloping a Rails app.
Should you use Yeoman, or
stick with the Rails
[? as a ?] pipeline.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
PAUL IRISH: I say pipeline.
Well, there's a lot of tooling
in the Rails ecosystem
already, and Yeoman's solving
the problem of there's not
much tooling on the client
side in JavaScript space.
And so I'd say that on the Rails
side, it's pretty much
you're over there already.
And in Yeoman, we also are
improving on our story for how
Yeoman can integrate with Rails,
and have Rails power
the Preview Server, but you
still have the Library
Compilation Functionality
still going.
And so as we're doing that,
that's ongoing, and we'll have
something to look at soon, but
in the meantime, I think Rails
as a pipeline would be--
MALE SPEAKER: Yep.
PAUL IRISH: I think
that'll be it.
and please join us next time
on the Breakpoint.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you for
joining us this time.
ADDY OSMANI: Thanks
for joining us.
We'll see you next time.